hello and welcome to this video playing
kid kid role played him before and
wonder game irritated by the way it is
displayed anyway so let's get going hmm
Queens gambit yeah the bishop waveform
and I have played for a really long time
a long time before it became fashionable
okay yeah I'm happy to take there are
weaknesses there on the light squares
okay
Bishop d3 yep the hanging pawn formation
is normally not that great against this
kind of setup look do you wanna I guess
okay interesting
would like to trade with Bishop e6 to
make the light squares more of an issue
for him you know actually already a bit
problematic because after the trade how
does he cover the a pond uh-huh if I go
queen b7 Quincy age 95 could be
interesting already he's got Quincy if I
get if I play rook c1 Quincy 8 is
probably okay
interesting I absolutely underestimated
that or overestimated my position this
is not so bad for black as I thought
Queeny form
Queeny for chrimbus fnet black is fine
mmm interesting so this this wasn't a
good plan really surprised that this
wasn't a good plan I thought I should be
at least somewhat better but I'm not
okay I don't think a bishop helps me
much yes so I'm trading it
before it's got to be five and Knight b6
that is not really good
okay I'm increasing I'm putting some
pressure on d5 so it cannot so easily
push c5 still not easy to make any
anything here like anything happened
before is the only pawn break that I
have again preventing c5
what I'm doing is very unimpressive but
I don't think I can do much so I have to
be content with what I have and try to
make the best best of it so yeah do you
want to go G for takes takes I have 96
that is a there is an idea at least so
let's try sorry
mmm interesting that he's not moving I
mean I think you have to take that
anyway yeah look e6 maybe a 95 96 is an
introduced isn't a threat it's a threat
the Queen on a6 is not particularly well
placed so 85 or do I have anything right
here
probably not I was rookie one moving
moving the Knight to c3 is going to be 8
now that's just equal
got 14 seconds oops oops
they're very interesting tactic b2 is
hanging
you know I will go age for after that
just wants to trade everything okay
that's very conservatively played you
came very Jewish but
how can I can I do something probably
not maybe I can fix something on dark
squares but it's so totally Jewish you
cannot fix even anything
54 hmm that's not good you can go to f/2
I wanted to play a three but this is not
a good it's not great
presenting f3 Knight f4
ah god damn it no what the heck there
was such unnecessary it's defending this
whole time and actually in a way that I
should not use anymore I think I mean I
blunder this it was extremely
unnecessary and now Bishop f4 I didn't
see it man it always drives me crazy you
have if you already have done it
basically and then you screw it up oh
yeah the plate you totally misplaced its
own pieces there it's probably still a
loss but let's go here yeah I think I
may have saved it oh yeah I saved it
okay Wow
I shouldn't do that maybe had G for them
Wow
I was extremely lucky after i blundered
us and came away there are some hot
moments there so I felt I really felt
that this Queenie - Bishop e6 was good
but it wasn't it really wasn't me it's
remarkable you can just take and put it
back on the edge and then it's ready for
Queen c8 and I've got basically nothing
you know okay I don't have anything but
I think I did a decent job here of
slightly improving engine likes before
here probably because um because here
Ruby 6 can be answered with 95 and I've
got 95 here this is not as convincing I
still can go 95 yeah ok I saw this idea
but I didn't think it was so great a
double attacking here I didn't see
Knight eg5 I was thinking of a different
way what was my idea there and it died
it slightly I had this idea actually
which doesn't work this this with this
and I'm not threatening much there 95
this shouldn't work ok because of Quincy
for me yeah he bluffed me yeah I got no
time and he bluffed me and he can just
take me to but she
strangely enough did not take and this
is very draw unless you play it as
stupidly as I did I should just not go
that way
yeah 94 I mean it's a draw
yeah I'm getting antsy here I mean
slight trouble really but I think the
way it went it was really okay after
this is trade now I should not lose any
more I got a good night before
maybe it's it's probably still a draw
but this is really this is very stupid
and this is very very very good yeah he
should win somehow
yeah Bishop f4 course was very simple
but it's still a complete loss neither
for Bishop f4 he s easy
yeah this is still losing G for now yeah
yeah I'm G for with the breakthrough now
here G form takes and you're promoting
now it's draw maybe there was one moment
where I think I may be allowed to fall
here
I thought G 4 I will okay I'm saved by
the Senate just about just a bar I was a
pretty blonde of who gaming by both
sides okay
thanks a lot for watching